each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
he has an MBA from Duke University and
her PhD from the University of Utah
she's before returning to academia she
worked an IBM for nine years in the
Research Triangle part she's going to
talk to us about some of her experiences
with doing industrial case studies in
extreme programming hi well thanks for
having me here today so what I'm going
to talk about is not you said is is for
industrial case studies that we did with
extreme programming teams one of our two
of them were at Sabre airline solutions
saber Airlines develops products that
support airline industries like
reservations baggage control things like
that we did two studies with them we did
one with IBM in Research Triangle Park
and one with tekelec which is a
telecommunications company in the
triangle tech elects claim to fame they
have two applications you might know of
one is they were the people that allowed
us to if you switch cellphone providers
you can keep the same phone number now
it's a big breakthrough check elected
that they also broke the logjam you know
there was one year with American Idol
where if you tried to vote it was always
a busy signal you hear that about that
and so they broke it so that last year
all the voting went smoothly so that the
public applications the tech likes done
so what I'm going to do today first of
all is provide a brief overview of
extreme programming to about a year ago
Kent Beck wrote the second edition of
the extreme programming explained book
and kind of redefined extreme
programming and so I'll give a brief
overview of that and then I'll talk
about the empirical studies we did and
please interrupt me at any time I hope
to learn as much about Microsoft as you
learn for me today and so I would
appreciate that with extreme programming
to one thing I'll say is that you know
there was five years between the first
book in the second book and the first
book I think that Kent was mostly
writing about his experiences and those
around them with teams not not a lot of
experience though
and as five years went by he saw what he
and others saw what teams really did and
what really worked and so the extreme
programming to book is a little more you
know and not as as arrogant about what
you had to do and didn't say you have to
do all things at one time it was kind of
sought much softer and maybe because one
of the authors of the book was Kent's
wife so maybe she put the female touch
into the book and and it's a little more
realistic I think and so what he did in
that book is break up the practices to
primary practices and corollary
practices on the primary practice serves
a narrow up at the top what ken says is
the primary practice is up at the top
are just plain good practices and you
can take any one of them and Institute
it with your team and have good results
that they do work best when you put them
together but you can do any one of them
and then the corollary practices at the
bottom our practice is that once you
have a core set of primary practices
instituted that you can start
instituting some of them as well I did
notice you may know I've done research
and pair programming and I did notice
they Kent left pair programming off of
the top of the chart trying not to be
insulted about that okay so what I ya
know it's missing missing so the what
the one thing I'll say to and I know
that this is televised so he could hear
me say this but in his acknowledgments
for his book he acknowledges his four of
his children he has five so that was the
worst mistake in the book and leaving
pair programming off the diagram though
he does say somewhere talks it he names
the other daughter that he missed but
then he said something about his
children he gets four names but that was
kind of an oversight so what I'm going
to do is I'll talk about the primary
practices of extreme programming and
I'll have a note like new meaning that
it was not an extreme program one it is
extreme programming to sustained rename
so I kind of have a comment to compare
extreme programming 12 Katrine
programming to sit together is a new
practice and
basically what it says it's good for
everyone to be sitting together in one
room and that's the sit together
practice I mean there's lots of research
that go back many years let's say this
war room type of approach is a good
thing I'm whole team is a new practice
and and again this is you know something
that goes back a long way basically it's
your you know cross-functional team so
get any of everyone on the team the
testers and developers quality assurance
customer representative customer get
everyone together on one team and he
talks about tipping points so 12 is the
number of people that can comfortably
interact in a day and so that's a good
team size or maximum team size and then
150 is the point at which you can't
recognize everyone's face that's on your
team and so when you have teams of teams
it's good not to go above 150 people
it's what he's saying informative
workspace is another new practice
basically just says you know when you
walk into a workspace where the team is
working you should be able to look on
the wall and find out how the team is
doing what progress is made what tests
are passing just you know that you can
get a good feel of what's going on
energized work is another practice which
you like the graphics the funny thing
about the graphics is I was trying to
get a picture of stereotypical geek
though that's what I wanted was geek so
I put geek into Google and looked at
images and found those and what would
energize work says used to be called
40-hour work week then it was renamed to
sustainable pace and now it's energized
work it's basically says to work it only
as many hours as you can be productive
and only as many hours as you can
sustain so don't work too much you guys
don't work too much you're doing no
pair programming is a practice that was
sustained two people working together at
one computer and then stories is
somewhat of an renamed partial practice
was in the planning game and called user
stories and the idea behind stories is
to have customer visible functionality
short statements of customer visible
functionality written on index cards as
your requirements document and the the
point of the story is that you you know
that you're going to have to talk to a
customer to clarify the requirement and
so it's a commitment for further
conversation between the customer and
the developer and so there's short
statements of requirements also putting
put on their priority statements and how
much resource it will take and then you
use those in a weekly cycle used to be
called the planning game where the
highest priority cards that can fit into
a certain amount of time or prioritize
for that weekly cycle and there's a
caveat there's another practice called
slack which comes into play here which
I'll talk about any questions so far and
trying to go through this kind of fast
quarterly cycle is another practice used
to be called small releases so basically
says within a quarter you should be able
to deliver functionality to a customer
and be able to get feedback from a
customer on that and that you need to be
delivering business value in that
quarter and then ya la vez
the quarterly is this small well you'll
see when we get to the corollary
practices he actually talks about daily
deployment so so i would say quarterly
is the large but in terms of delivering
value to customer or business as
quarterly is he think we release this
month junk of time you spend i would say
largest chunk of time so you should you
should deliver value to your customer at
least every quarter and one of the
corollary practices is daily deployment
and that would only work if you had
something like a web application where
you could deploy new functionality the
web application so slack is a new
practice lexus in every weekly cycle
planned some low priority tasks so that
if if you have to drop something out
that you drop a low priority task out
and the customer isn't upset because
you're not missing an important
commitment for the customer and then
another new practice is 10 minute build
so you should be able to automatically
build and test your whole system in 10
minutes
well you know every time I've shown this
flight and talk to anyone in industry
you know they always say there's just no
way and so you know i would say in one
hand it's its idealistic to think you
can do that on the other hand it
probably challenge you to think what can
we do during the day so that we can get
feedback as often as possible but you
know 10 minutes is a very short period
of time
continuous integration is another
sustained practice basically says you
have these small tasks when you finish
your small task and your test case runs
for that small task that you put it into
the codebase run all of the tests over
the whole code base and then put it into
the code base and I remember having an
enlightening discussion last time I gave
a talk here about three years ago
because of the Microsoft secrets book I
had the impression that you guys did bet
daily builds and had new functionality
every night and at that point I was
informed that you have a daily build but
you don't put a new functionality into
that daily Bild right that's what I was
told at that time and we only put new
functionality in every few cool every
few months is that now you do put in
your functionality good and then test
first programming is another sustained
practice which has really two levels
first is the acceptance test level that
every feature has an acceptance test in
it and that feature is considered to be
finished when the acceptance test case
passes and then there's another level of
cycle which is a unit test cycle that
your writing unit tests and passing them
continuously throughout the development
on a minute-by-minute basis incremental
design is kind of a renamed practice i
would say used to be called simple
design and refactoring together and so
what it says is no big design up front
it's knowledge-based design so that you
have your most effective design when you
have experience like the previous day's
development experience will help you
with your design for today still the
philosophies of do the simplest thing
that could possibly work can't emphasize
isn't the that can possibly work in this
book because he said I get the
impression he's gotten a lot of flak
about that and you know how could we do
this you know what how could we not
consider security and how can we not do
this and you know saying well that could
not possibly work then you need to
consider everything that you need to
consider in your implement
asian refactoring is an important aspect
of the incremental design so that when
you have code that's working then you
take relook at the design of the
implementation and and improve it and
it's very important that you have unit
tests to protect you when you do that
redesign and you will see as we look at
the empirical studies the bank of unit
tests really impact the refactoring
practice if you don't have a lot of unit
tests it's very difficult to refactor so
that's the summary of the XP two primary
practices in a comparison chart and so
if you look at the XP XP two primary
practices there are five new practices
several renamed practices and several
sustained practices and there were four
practices that were in the first version
of extreme programming that are no
longer there and my interpretation is
that Kent saw that these practices teams
didn't do and they succeeded so maybe
they weren't as necessary as he thought
and I'll talk about some of them one of
the metaphor the metaphor practice and
all of the studies we've done no one has
ever really that used the metaphor
practice the metaphor practice said that
you should think of some kind of an
analogy for your team your project and
name things according to the analogy and
teams just really didn't do that and
that's just removed collective code
ownership was moved to a corollary
practice and I'll quickly go through
those and renamed a shared code on site
customer which you know I would have
thought would have been a primary
practice but as we did studies in many
cases people didn't have on-site
customers and they were successful that
got moved to a corollary practice called
real customer involvement and coding
standard was removed okay any questions
or reactions to those yeah why was
coding senator
give me why was coding standing with me
you know he never explained wife and he
just is absent you know so he didn't
explain why anything was removed he just
said this is what it is and I don't know
if he maybe he thought that was so basic
everyone does it and he didn't have to
say it in it I'm not sure any other
question okay and I will go quickly
through the corollary practices first of
all real customer involvement was called
on-site customer and what that said was
that a customer needed to be available
to answer questions to clarify
requirements and like I said with the
studies we've done in most cases they
didn't have that and a lot of papers
that I've read you know that that's a
very difficult thing to do to get a
customer to actually be on site but how
valuable is it in your research how
valuable I guess so
it would help but I can't really
quantify how valuable it would be so and
in all of our cases and I'll talk
through them there was never an on site
and they were successful and that's why
that's my opinion why you got moved
because it works you know email and
other things seem to work but there have
been other papers that talk about how
good it is not quantifying it and
talking about how time consuming it is
and what a difficult job it is so I
think it could be valuable but it can be
a little impractical as well yeah India
floating around what's no doubt misty
not floating around
the customer insane
if you have the customers sign off what
it is that you're building right because
if they're on site if you just got to
chat with that being like this how is
that but they're not be potentially or
does their process of normalizing
different partner right and so I mean
I'll speak from our case studies and
some we've done other case studies in
these for just not to the level of
detail is that there is always a
responsive customer ready to talk on the
phone reddit to instant message ready to
answer an email and so the same type of
thing happens it just doesn't happen
with them physically in the room and
that's in all cases so with the customer
close at hand does it cause so great you
know the changing of how things are
getting and cause the scope to change I
don't think so and I think because
there's a you know that weekly outlook
and so you know then if the customer
wants something to change then they have
to pull something off you know and so
they need to make that trade-off and and
because of that explicit trade-off I
think things stay in line change yeah
and it's not even signed off it's more
informal than that
but you know they can watch which user
stories are in the iteration and if they
change if they want to bring something
in then you know they have to take
something out to be fair yeah
okay another one incremental deployment
is a new practice and so this says to
get your customers to actually deploy
your software more often rather than
have this big bang whole new financial
system on Monday kind of thing to have
specific bits of functionality so that
they can be replacing their other
application team continuity is a new
practice and it basically says if you
have a team that works well together
keep them together and what goes along
with that is shrinking team that says as
the team gets better because they've
worked together longer and they have
more experience then don't add to the
team shrink the team just say okay you
know we have the same capacity but so
once I was leaving and now we're going
to have a smaller team no I have not
root cause analysis is a new corollary
practice and much sure how much you do
root cause analysis here what do you do
here do you do much of that not much so
requires analysis says we had a defect
what caused that defect had it added
that defect escaped and so the the way
that he's advocating doing would cause
analysis is you have a defect reported
by a customer or system test or
something and the first thing you do is
you write an acceptance test case that
will fail because of that defect and
then you write a unit test or multiple
unit tests that will fail because of
that defect and then you get your unit
tests to pass and then you get your
acceptance test to pass and so you see
what you know what caused the problem
and and what you had to do to fix it and
then you then you analyze how did that
happen what kind of test didn't we write
how did that escape to the field so I
think it's a good practice shared code
is now in a corollary practice that says
base yeah good cause
since there's some sort of feedback that
says okay now you put this in the best
practices or hey how does that learning
go back to the teeth of Ruth well it
remember the teams are small and so all
of this happens within the same room
ideally and so you can you know actually
I've seen your cousin else has done more
in big companies like IBM where there
would be a root cause analysis meeting
and so the team would actually study
things you know I've never seen them
programming team because this is a new
practice I don't know how formal it is
or if it's just personal learning you
know you see this process yourself and
then you know what to do better next
time so shared code says that anyone on
the team can change anyone else's code
and that's a corollary practice now and
it has some strong prerequisites pair
programming being one of them so that
you know you're when you're changing
someone else's code at least two of you
think you should make that change
continuous integration meaning you put
that change into the build make sure it
doesn't break anything and test first
programming so you have a lot of tests
unit tests that will tell you if that
change is good or bad
within the team but not across right
right did you hear her question so the
the shared code being within the team
not within the team of teams and then
codon Tess is a new practice which just
says the only the only thing they should
archive our code and tests no
documentation and then you should rely
on social mechanisms to keep alive the
rest of the history of the project that
any other documentation becomes obsolete
and so you need executable documentation
so so no business requirement document
no business requirement document no
customer data customer data problems he
has
persona I would say no I mean although
those some things like personas and
those seem like business related things
where this is actually implementation
code kind of things so this doesn't say
the whole life cycles only keep is to
say more for the development right oh
good right but it would mean no design
documents and things like that so API
documentation so he probably stayed put
it in Java doc and things like that no
oh and I would say yeah did bug
database like if this is focus on the
product my my reader that our business
that didn't say you don't document
things
it said don't bother spending energy
maintaining
it was much design on
solve problems but there's no sense to
try and keep that up to date as the code
of all changes it's just a tool to solve
the immediate problem that makes
yeah and I thank you for that
clarification because I did I didn't
take this permanent artifacts is the key
and so you do what you need to do and
actually even and I'll get to you in one
second even if your customer says design
the design document is important to me
the high priority item and it would be
in the iteration but it's not an
advisable thing to do this is what he
advises but it was always like do the
simplest documentation that could
possibly work as well as everything else
so a lot of times on in regards to the
code in tests so working without a BRD
I've done projects taking the VR game
were able to every are denied spent a
lot of departments okay okay and we have
some time to go back up Dasia business
requirements but because all the rules
are in the test cases and that sort of
serves as a
the test cases really aren't all that
the 2-minute helps us down some
right right i don't know if it i'll try
to translate what he said if you didn't
hear it but if you start out and this
this is you know it would be the way to
go and not violate anything here if you
start at it with a business requirements
document and translate that into the
code into tests preferably automated
tests and then the business you don't
have to throw the business requirements
document away conserve whatever purpose
it serves but then you have these
executable acceptance test case kind of
things that would really document the
requirements and you know you would know
if they were obsolete because you would
run them in it would fail and so that's
a way to keep it up to date so this
bullet seems to be really very much time
to the previous one that said keep your
team together forever right this says
rely on institutional memory not paper
and the only way that's achievable is if
you never
well so I
yeah so so one thing I'll say so so yes
yes and no so these corollary practices
do say you had are doing the primary
practices then you can start these so
yes for that keep them together forever
is probably a stretch and it is that the
code and the tests are the executable
documentation and so we're a paper
document can become obsolete you know
something that executes its it's up to
date and so a test case an executable
test case is it you know as effective
our requirement as a requirements
document and that that can be kept up to
date and can live with the and I won't
say that I can be laying information
another thing I agree with all the
information so question about functional
specs I mean to me that's always like
the English way of understanding what
the product say it's something that a
lot of people in the team can understand
chair what does he say about that they
really go away and good so how does
somebody like a PM understand what that
features really doing about going yeah
what what's being built they have you
agree on the common definition what's
being built and tested if you don't have
a function
yeah so functional specs definitely do
go away except that you do whatever you
have to do and so you can you can draw
up whatever you want de-emphasizing
having it be pretty and nice and
archival so whatever you need to do in
order for your team to work together you
know whether it be a whiteboard that
never gets erased or anything in between
to get the job done you have you be just
for just effort at me I'm really just in
your research
okay okay okay so there was one more
hand out before I go yeah go away the
reasons
cheers as he said like the actual
functionality of a code would be
maintained in the code and in the test
themselves the reasons why something was
developed the way it was developed it's
not is that okay to lose that
information especially as you go forward
and decide to change a feature you're
like why do we do this this way without
thinking of all the reasons why dollars
yeah and I think that would be one of
the things that rely on social
mechanisms ok and as much as it's you
know debating practices you'll see some
of this reoccur when I talk about the
empirical studies as well so these are
three that are you know probably a
little more far-fetched and would be
dependent on your type of
application so daily deployment says put
note new code into production every
night and like I said the only way I can
see something like that happening is if
you have a web application and you can
put new functionality out there you
certainly can't do it to regular
customers negotiated scope contract you
have fixed time cost and quality but
call for ongoing negotiation of scope
and pay-per-use charge for every time
the systems used so it's kind of like
every time you make a phone call that
software it's used his reasoning behind
this was that you'll be able to tell if
your software is high quality or not by
how much it's used but you know again
you can't do that in many many cases so
okay so those are the practices and so
now I'll go on to the studies that we
did and so all of the studies were
structured based on what we call the
extreme programming evaluation framework
and what we wanted to do before we
develop the evaluation framework we you
know read lots and lots of papers I'll
just call them success stories of teams
you probably have read them too they
would appear in the literature and it
didn't have a real structure to it and
they weren't never measuring the same
thing and so from a researcher
standpoint you can't develop a body of
evidence if every time someone does a
study they measure something else and so
we have a framework that has three main
categories first is context factors
that's that says you know what's the
side of the team the language lines of
code just basic demographic kind of
information
that would help you as a consumer of the
information to know is this team like my
team is there any similarity between
this team and my team from a reach
researchers standpoint we can find the
you know the limits we could build up a
body of evidence and understand well
this works for small co-located teams
but as soon as you have them
geographically distributed things break
apart you know we can we can see what
the differences are and we can see that
by watching the context factors then we
have XP adherence metrics and so that
basically says did the team do extreme
programming and so it goes through the
practices and tries to assess whether or
not they did it and you know you'll hear
I've had lots of conversations with
teams that say you know we tried extreme
programming and it failed and when I
really got down to it you know they
didn't do test for programming they
didn't do pair programming all they just
did they didn't do design that's all the
only and I mean I can't tell you how
many people I talked to wear that was
the case where I mean I would say did
you do this no no but you know what we
really wish we had that design document
when it all it's like well of course
because you didn't do any of the others
and so what we wanted to capture is what
is the team doing both from you know
seeing whether they did extreme
programming at all and also watching for
trends between which practices seem to
be essential in which don't so that's
the adherence metrics and then the
outcome measures are your basic business
related results like productivity
quality things like that that a business
person would care about so so it manages
you know the reason what's the result of
this adoption just as a side note we
also have evaluation frameworks for the
team software process and the rational
unified process and from a presentation
one of my PhD students did last week I
think you guys are doing a lot of team
software processes that right there's a
whole bunch of people from Microsoft at
the sei interest
oh very big company it's a corporate
standoff Frankie Department tsps
corporate sander okay
so the first thing that we worked with
was an IBM team in Research Triangle
Park and the first two case studies i'll
talk about or what i'll say our small
co-located teams and that's kind of in
the context of what what should an
extreme programming like the original
literature said 10 to 12 no more than 10
to 12 co-located object-oriented
programmers and the first two case
studies fit right into that this IBM
team was an island of extreme
programming in the middle of an IBM
culture and so they had they did not
have management saying you should do
extreme programming they had a champion
in the department who said I want to do
extreme programming and was influential
enough with his teammates to convince
them to do extreme programming and work
together as a team you know to get their
own training and you know they just had
the kind of culture that that's the kind
of thing that the team wanted to do and
he was able to do that this champion
also had to do some work to fit into the
minimum set of interfaces so he might
create he might take the user stories
and type them into a document to call
them requirements he took it upon
himself to do that so he you know just
did all of the things he had to do in
order to not I'm ruffle any feathers
within IBM so small co-located team they
did web development they took some code
from an IBM team worked on it and then
sent it on to another IBM team all three
of those teams being in different
geographical locations and because of
that that's why he especially had to
document requirements and some
interfaces and things like that because
that was expected along the way and what
we did was we examined an old release to
a new release on the team had already
begun to do some extreme programming
like things because they didn't like
heavy process so they were they weren't
starting from Ground Zero and you'll see
this chart on a lot of the teams this is
a polar chart developed by Barry bein at
university of southern california and
and the point of his polar chart is that
if you look at the factors on the chart
which i'll go through
if the team's factors are far from the
middle of the polar chart then that says
that's a plan driven so his it's a jalar
plan driven and so if the point is above
you know far away from the center then
that's a plan driven type of factor
where if it's close to the center then
that would say this this is a good thing
for agile and so that the five things he
talks about first of all personnel up at
the top that says what's the skill level
of the team and it's not currently mean
you could be a person who has worked and
as a programmer for a really long time
and not have a high skill level when you
go into a new department because you're
learning new domain and so I highly
skilled person would be able to be
technically sound and also be able to
change procedures because they were
comfortable enough in order to do that
and so if you're highly skilled you'd be
towards the center if the team had left
skilled people it would be towards the
outside meaning those people more likely
to need the documents that aren't
producing extreme programming the next
is dynamism so percentage of
requirements change if it's outside that
says these requirements are really
stable inside says these requirements
change a lot I'm the reasoning being if
your requirements are really stable and
are never going to change why not just
have a requirements document and gopher
you know go through it why do we need
all this customer interaction we know
exactly what they want the next one is
culture so the percentage of people in
the team that thrive on chaos vs order
so if you thrive on chaos extreme
programming is good and you go towards
the middle if you survive on order you
go towards the outside size of team so
agile is good for small teams maybe not
for large teams and criticality so if
you have a defect in this code what is
the impact loss of comfort so if it's a
game you know some kid gets mad would be
towards the middle and outside many
lives could be lost and so if you look
at the product and the team you graph
these factors and so looking at this IBM
team the factor that's most plan driven
is the criticality because an
organization could lose critical funds
if there's a defect
for the most part that looks you know
the shape is fairly towards the center
and it looks like an agile methodologies
probably fine for this team yeah the
culture one is based on I'll talk about
this show dance survey which is so it's
a subjective measure based on a survey
that's what I'll say and the context
factors in the evaluation framework are
many more than this so this is just a
high-level overview and so the adherence
metrics and this is the show dance
survey so we have one thing and this was
developed by IBM called the show tunes
survey and it basically asks the
developers to go through the practices
and say when you know how much do you do
them and so it's very subjective it is
anonymous so they're not you know they
don't have an incentive to say they do
something that they don't do but yet
it's subjective but if you look at the
team they had a score of 56 percent and
then as they instituted more of extreme
programming they went to seventy-two
percent it's really hard to say you know
we're seventy two percent XP you know
it's really not a good measure but that
the change does tell us something and
what we try to do is to take the
subjective measures and add as many
objective metrics as we possibly can we
can't do all of them because its heart
of metrics say the team can't interfere
with this we're going to measure
something that they can't manipulate and
it's hard to do that with some of the
practices many of the practices actually
but we're working on it as much as we
possibly can the survey results for this
IBM team the things that were low for
them refactoring was low and if we ask
him why it's because they didn't have
the unit tests that they needed to have
metaphor was really not used at all and
then some of the others that come out
here the first several objective metrics
relate to testing and this is a team
that really wanted to try to get the
testing institute as much as possible
but we're dealing with a lot of legacy
code and that's that's a problem when
you try to institute automated testing
and so if you look at some of the things
we measure it's like automated test
class per user story it was eleven
percent of
had automated tests went to 45%
statement coverage went from thirty to
forty six percent unit test runs per day
actually went down so that wasn't so
great the ratio of tesla's the code to
source lines of code went from point2
62.4 to someone in an extreme
programming would say that should be
about a one to one you should basically
have the same number of tests lines of
code to source lines of code and so you
know they got better but still have a
ways to go they were still had manual
acceptance test cases that the customer
did not run so you know they they made
some progress in testing but still had a
ways to go pairing frequency went from
five percent of forty-eight percent and
it jumped that much because they had a
you know a ruling basically said if you
don't pay air you have to have your code
inspected and so they had a trade-off
there and when they have that trade-off
that the pair programming went up
release what lengths went down by about
half and they had weekly iterations any
questions about that yeah no it's no
problem
there
have your productivity time
going over here
so I'll say as a whole and research I've
done it and others as well as pairing
doesn't double the amount of time it
takes it actually can be almost you
finish almost in half the time and so
you know it that was the research i did
but others have done as well and will
some will even say that it's even faster
than double and doing it myself i can
see you can feel and I don't know if
anyone here wants to say that they do it
and their experiences you're shaking
your head right I mean it's kind of like
you wonder why did that happen and the
other person says oh that happened
because of it's just it's just very fast
yeah right right there's a lot of that
you know you won't answer you won't
answer your phone so I'm going to walk
up and see oh they're working and walk
away I mean there's a lot of reasons why
your productivity can get better you're
both concentration flying plane
and it is really fast I mean when I've
done it and it's really fast so that
after a while you just have to stop
because you know you get to a point
where you just can't do it anymore and
then you go answer your phone and do
your email and things like that my
concept project exposed to gravity
the concepts that you don't
I mean project
mm-hmm yep yep thanks for that I'm and
then the other trade-off is that IBM
it's not and then you just show your
code to someone else it's actually a
formal inspection so it would involve
five people for people so any other
questions and so what happened to this
team first of all they had twenty-three
percent requirement change throughout
the iteration they we measured two
things first of all is pre-release
quality so test defects per line of code
and they had half the test defects per
line of code and so that's kind of I'll
call it a surrogate measure because that
could say well we didn't test very much
you know I mean it's hard to say what
that really measures but actually they
had double the number of tests in for
the new release than the old release
they ran all over old releases tests as
well as another whole set and so if they
did tests as much post-release quality
is released defects per line of code and
that was for the first nine months after
release and they had basically sixty
percent productivity is very difficult
to measure so we offer three measures
one is stories for person month lines of
code for person month and then something
called the putnam productivity parameter
which actually kind of trusted
normalized for a number of people on the
team and elapsed time and lines of code
and if you look at all of those metrics
that you know all say that the team is
more productive than they were before
but again and there's a caveat because
the none of those are exact measures
yeah you see point six one six thousand
blames of executable
okay thanks for asking that question
it's actually a normalized value so IBM
doesn't want you to know what their
their defect density is and so there's
one owes in all of the old because that
was the baseline and so basically it's
saying 61 percent of the old value that
makes sense ok telling us right right
they don't want you to know when you
don't want them to know our you're
talking about two releases of an ongoing
project in here so to which extent with
the accumulated knowledge have gotten
have have resulted in these improvements
anyway yeah it's hard to say and so all
in all with with industrial case studies
I mean it they there are more compelling
to people like you because if I came in
and talked about student studies and all
these exact things wouldn't be so
interested in it but there are
limitations such as what's the learning
that takes place what it's specific
people on the team you know it's six
specific people and so all of these
things are limitations of all case
studies yeah
hi yeah how are they measuring its
Fiserv I mean not by survey by interview
so when we when what we would do is
actually talk to the customer of the
product which in this case was another
IBM organization and we have a survey in
you know in the evaluation framework we
have a template for the survey that we
ask customers and interviews so in terms
of time where they SAT highly satisfied
because the releases were shorter or
faster they were more was the quality my
own right to quality and functionality
by now ok if were they aware of this way
of releasing the XP or they had no no
they knew that the other team was doing
XP but as I said that the champion kind
of buffered them as much as possible so
they knew there was a change but they
didn't they had minimum impact due to
the change Lori how would you categorize
their initial quality in the old so
without telling me the defects per lane
of course number because this forty
percent reduction doesn't strike me it's
very impressive well
so was this already a very good team
yeah customer was a register then they
were even happier they had a respectable
defect density yoga's you know I've seen
numbers like that ninety-eight percent
improvement 89 I'm saying ninety-nine
point something for saying going from
truly lousy to really good and you know
there's documentation and electrical
that says you'll get five or six defects
per line of code and you can drive that
down to less than three pair ten
thousand lines of code so that number of
forty percent isn't very impressive so
knowing what the one point or really
represents is important so one thing
I'll say is percent improvement is not
what I'm showing here so if they if so
ninety-eight percent improvement would
be a point five or ninety nine percent
so that would mean it would go down by
half so this is this is saying if it was
five then it's I can't do that math in
my head it was three so it was one
defect there are thousands lanes of cord
it's no point six one
right
but they definitely had respectable
quality it wasn't an issue before and
then morale was based on that showed in
survey again and so Kent Beck will say
teams are happier when they use pair
programming it you know they improved on
their morale score on that how many I a
duration of XP like I mean or these is
today go through between old and new I
mean visit should the first time through
they already had these improvements are
like after five cycles kind of
stabilized right so they had weekly
iterations and so this was one release
to the next release back to back over
five months right and some of the others
that there are bigger breaks in between
but this was one release to the next
release but there was five months in
between okay okay sabre sabre has two
case studies we one is called saber a
because they were more
characteristically agile saber p is the
next case study because they were more
characteristically plan driven so one
thing about saber is that the vice
president of development said we are
doing extreme programming to his team
all 250 people doesn't matter what your
product is what the team size that we're
doing it so that was very different than
the IBM case and so they had somewhere
like an IBM you know they were XP says
use open space well they didn't have it
they didn't have support for facilities
changes that had that kind of support
and saber and they didn't have to fight
any battles starts making documents that
they didn't need or anything like that
so if you look at the polar charts for
the before and after for the most part
all of their factors said this is good
for an agile team culture was the one
the team was resistant they know they
wanted more order than extreme
programming was going to allow but the
after you can see that they they got
used to it some of the people change as
well as as they were fine with what
happened you can see there's from mid
two thousand two two late two thousand
three so there are several releases in
between in which they were getting used
to extreme programming so by the time
they got too late two thousand three
they were quite used to extreme
programming and so
the biggest changes you know they had a
waterfall process they went to extreme
programming still small team you know
six to ten people not a lot of turnover
they were co-located they had overseas
customers this is a case where they had
they had an on-site customer marketing
representative that was responsive to
them and they had a lot of email contact
with their customers overseas they had
double the number of customers for the
new release which does have an impact on
defect density when you have more people
using the product they went you know
Java and C++ they did have open laps
that was one thing that the vice
president provided for them was open
labs a lot less person month so they
went from i think it was ten to three
months no 18 month to three and a half
months iteration re-release times so
much less lines much less personal
months and much less lines of similar
lines of code house knelt on over and
the culture matric is that because the
people who didn't want to be I child
just like the project so during 2367
percent my six listening you have during
the raid people well for the most part
no but I will say you know when we went
to Sabre there were not they were not
universally happiness about all of this
there were some people that did not
think this was the way to go but in this
particular team that that was not the
cause of the turnover
and then for as far as adherence metrics
when they took the survey this we didn't
have a old survey we only had the new
team do the survey seventy-seven percent
and there's a lot of similarities
between the teams so they didn't do
refactoring as much if you look at the
testing metrics they're testing metrics
are better than IBM's I won't go through
each one one by one but they were trying
to do testing running into legacy code
problems which impacted things like
refactoring didn't do metaphor so like
if you looked at the IBM team the saber
team extremely similar they also went up
to fifty percent pairing from basically
none and again they had you know
inspection versus it's a common theme
have inspections were sepehr programming
and then I said their release length
went down and they didn't have it
erations before so before they had one
18-month release nothing in the middle
now they had 10 day releases three and a
half or 10-day iterations arena have
length release so a lot more feedback
along the way and if you look at their
metrics they didn't keep on track of the
requirements changes but again you know
higher quality and one of the things so
pre-release quality they had much less
defects but you know that that metric
needs to be considered because you have
to measure the test quality itself the
post release quality went down and you
won't be impressed by it but they had
doubled the number of customers and and
the defect density went down so they had
two things that happened there on
productivity see my said they're already
quite good
but if their initial quality was
industry standard load which is six
defects per function point six defects
para fundraiser lanes called hundred
planes alright then a third percent
improvement
doesn't reflect the amount of pasting
and appearing in that kind of thing with
fairly good test coverage imperium you'd
expect the driver though significantly
if you're starting a very good level of
quality then obviously it's difficult
right and so and actually not choose my
PhD student behind you and he's worked
with Sabre some and one thing I'll say
about saber they do have very high
quality their their applications are
airline reservation systems baggage
handling I mean so these are things that
they can't tolerate and so they have
high they always had high quality
testing my jersey though he writes about
saver o Devi and what does he say cuz
I'll show you the next taste I think I'm
ready to book myself but I believe he
talks about agile methodologies that
were used
the projects that he was involved with
right and and I don't know what what he
says in the long run does he say it
worked or didn't more he's the proponent
of it so no no I mean I didn't read his
book and I'll say you know when we
talked to the team they definitely
surface at the next case study you'll
see it in spades and I also the vice
president development that started this
all he did tell me I guess it was a year
ago at the agile conference that one
that he start even though we said all
teams do it he was starting to believe
at that point so this was summer of 2000
for that teams with large legacy code
bases may not be the best candidates and
so I don't know what Michael says but
that's what he's hearing from his team
and so one thing I'm not I'm not
incriminating Michael at all but in
general a lot of the books written by
the you know extreme programming
advocates advocate that it will work in
all situations okay customer
satisfaction high and again this is
anecdotal based on interviews morale
sixty-eight percent there's really no
reference point that's that's based on
the survey but we don't have a pre
number so this is the saber p meaning
that it would be primarily a plan driven
kind of product and if you look at the
polar charts some things that you can
see the less skilled department not very
much requirements change team thrives on
order Lord your team 15 s not that big
but it is larger than the others and in
this application would only loose
discretionary fund so that was the
factor that was mostly agile but the
rest of them would say that this team
might have some struggles with extreme
programming based on those factors this
was the 13th release of the product and
it was after 20 months of using extreme
programming and it was a large web
application with a million line of code
code base and the customers were
domestic and overseas
so if you look at what they did and you
can basically look at your to those
testing metrics and see that they had a
lot of trouble testing so their
automated test class / new change class
was point 0 to 25 test coverage seven
point seven percent and this is over the
code base it's not over just a new code
it was it would be too hard to identify
that unit test runs per day so they ran
every two days and then the ratio of
tesla's Takoda source lines of code
still quite low so the team tried to do
it but they they just couldn't do it
they did have seventy percent pairing
release length of three months and
iteration ten days and so one thing I'll
say is there's not an old and new
release we didn't have any historical
data on this team so we just studied
what they were doing and what we did was
compared them to industry standards and
so we only had a few that we could look
at industry standard wise pre-release
defect density are our standards were
the Bangalore spin benchmarking group
and capers Jones and so based on those
benchmarks they had similar pre-release
defect density or lower depending on the
standard and then total defect density
which is pre-release plus post release
and this was in the first four months
after release and it there defect
density was lower than industry
standards in both productivity similar
or higher to industry standards
the text coverage perhaps the equivalent
substandard that's clearly the coverage
of the number that comes out suspect
densities yeah I can't say I mean so
their test coverage was low as you saw
but what I see in many cases just an
empty any team is that test coverage is
really lowered or a non-existent lots of
teams don't test very well and then the
last case studies tekelec on the tekelec
case study was interesting in that it
was a geographically distributed team
and so there was consultants or
contractors in Czech Republic working
with the tekelec team in Raleigh and
they developed a simulator for
telecommunication signal transfer point
in which they train new customers in
this one because it is a simulator they
didn't care about us releasing defect
information so you'll see what it is for
this team because it's not their product
it's just a simulator they had
considerable amount of requirements
volatility so this team I'm you know
really try to embrace the spirit of
extreme programming even though they
were geographically distributed so if
you look at their and it was a brand new
product it was new simulator so they had
a better chance than other groups and so
they had an automated test class for
every changed Clinton newer change class
they didn't tell us their test coverage
they ran the entire suite of unit tests
every day and then they had what they
called a quick set which was a small
subset of tests that they ran once an
hour there on ratio Teslin szkoda source
lines of code was 0 point 9 1 pair
programming seventy-seven percent for
months release and 10 day iteration and
so they really did try to do extreme
programming as much as possible and we
again this was a new product we had
nothing to compare it against they
didn't tell us their pre-release quality
measures they did tell us their post
release quality measures which was 1.6
to defect four lines of code which is
lower than industry standards customer
satisfaction in various areas so
capability the customer was fine with it
overwhelmed reliability they were
satisfied and the communication with the
team they were very satisfied with
productivity if you put the test coat in
there with lower than industry standards
or if you don't put the test code in
there which was basically you know
doubling the lines of code that they
wrote they were lower when you put the
test code in they were higher but you
don't you shouldn't put the test code in
so their productivity was lower than
industry standards right but some things
that came out so they did extreme
programming as much as they did but you
need to know about some other things
that the team did to manage this
distance and so when we did this
research we came up with some
conjectures of what does it take to make
this successful with a distributed team
and so one of the conjectures is that
you need a well-defined customer
authority which is part of extreme
programming and it's kind of obvious but
the first month that the team worked the
the customer representative was was
waffling around and not making
commitments and the team struggled and
then just simply by replacing that
person then the team got back on track
so it's it's very important another
thing that the team did was they had the
development manager who was from the
Czech Republic sitting in Raleigh and
then the rest of the team was in the
Czech Republic and that turned out to be
something major you know so that there
was no language barrier and there was no
culture barrier and so they bridged the
gap for that team they had prompt
responses to asynchronous queries
meaning that every day when the czech
republic would email questions about
requirements or anything else that they
knew that they were going to have an
answer when they woke up the next
morning and so they can rely on having
those answers and that was very
important to the team also having access
to product process and product
information so they use the x planner
tool which was online anyone in the team
could look at what was done what the
requirements were how people were doing
so but on both the development
managers part the team's part everybody
could see everything that was going on
at all times and that was very important
for the team and so to summarize if you
look at the various aspects that we look
at in research pre-release quality when
you look across generally looks like
pre-release quality does improve
post-release quality across the board
improved product or productivity you
know is kind of mixed where two case
studies would say that productivity did
improve three you know the third one
similar or higher and then the last one
looks like did not improve however that
was a distributed team and so you know
we don't have a standard for distributed
teams customer satisfaction looks you
know guess to neutral to very satisfied
and team morale not many data points but
the team was happy so this is a summary
and then I have a slide which has all
the papers if you wanted to go and read
the papers about these case studies so I
can open up for general questions now so
do you guys do any of these practices
anyone do extreme programming so what do
you do the whole thing or some some and
which which are the some of the sums
design
fo sho
most of the engineering practices
the project random
we actually just implemented a visual
studio 2005 application we used a
technology called click once which
allowed us to basically build our
environment roll it out and distribute
it dollar and are all our users with it
and within less than 10 minutes just a
few minutes actually I am so we built
this whole application in the last month
that we did in smaller with business we
turn that into test cases so that we'd
have a for every requirement a test that
had to pass or fail mm-hmm then we have
the team work together in pairs
sometimes seemingly but also in Paris so
that we can and that helped us a lot to
spot defects one person could easily see
what the other person was missing and
then everyone had access to all of the
code so everyone could see each other
with everything back in and they got the
latest versions everyone's they're
always able to build and see to quickly
build a whole bunch of versions of this
get customer feedback constantly we had
our customers on site with us a lot and
it really helped a lot to work in this
fashion I don't think we could have
achieved what we did a such a short
period of time without using these
methodologies great good yeah
select sounds very kind of rigid
framework of Texas people they have been
developers at the PX investors a lot of
what it contains programming does far
dr. stan is Glenda
let those rolls sound weapon
so how does it
I can use that for my team under visual
studio all rpms can code all our testers
can code we often share the burden of
writing the code fix protocol in Arizona
we're really Gloria distinction
in fact this answers your question to
you that would compete with a bad
decision versus your point too we don't
mind functional aspects too much because
of
thinking at least any other comments
what this does what with these
methodologies do for indoctrination of
new people into the team has done some
some interviews and some research into
how people program at Microsoft and
there's a tremendous variation
uptake of agile methodologies but one of
the things that seems so difficult about
seven offices and you work on your bag
at work for mine is the new yeah
definitely so the question was really
does this help new people and it
absolutely it helps new people if you
come in and you pair with a different
person every day and everyone's
co-located in the same room new people
it really helps on the flip side some
people who would consider the self
experts say I don't want to deal with
that and I would say that if someone is
an expert and doesn't want to work with
new people then they shouldn't be forced
to do it because it won't be good for
either either side any other questions
yeah
that seemed to be the what's that
beginner's mind in the beginner's mind
and thus he be the most quantitative
study it looks like about how people can
be helped and it looks like a huge
impact the Denver conference so that
being said when does that spark off any
interest with you or with anyone else
you know University to my feet Justin
furthering to study this is basically is
only one taste and right I companies up
business now how fair just to say that
but currently the software production
part was successful community more
quantitative stuff about about that yeah
and you know I'll say that I've not been
successful even over five years getting
companies to let me study pair
programming they let me study the whole
thing we're not one particular practice
and so replicating studies is a good
thing especially if you make the context
you know more generalizable and the
numbers and so you know if I had a
volunteer I would do it do you want to
volunteer where you going night prove
that doing what's of tasting improves
quality
creations and proves faulty productivity
and we we could have predicted not so
what's next oh so you validate it that's
great right and so um I would say that
I'm interested in looking where where
does it you know where are the boundary
so I would I think companies is like
you're saying everyone's saying ok short
iterations are good we should do that
obviously unit tests are good and so the
lot of the practices are just being done
now and that's great and maybe extreme
programming will fade away and some of
the good practices will be practices
everybody uses but what I'm interested
in and that's one of the reasons we got
to Rupp and we got 2 TSP and you know we
could do a Microsoft process as well is
looking at what what is the make of a
process and what's the best process for
the right team you know you have the
parameters of a team in a project what's
the right process and so and what are
the lines around that and maybe it's
interchangeable based on culture so
maybe a team software process or extreme
programming would both work for a
certain team and then it's the
personality of the team that could
choose study was the region because at
the moment the end is just seems to be
in a I brand myself by my intuition land
so kayne sweepers a four-week education
guy in Craig lammons three weeks and
Kent Beck was two weeks but he went to
one week occasionally one day and Ron
Jeffries is still kind of a to regain
you know to me that does a patently Rome
you know one when Hitler agent length
does not fit all situations yeah i agree
with that and so it would be hard to
study it in that respect i just think
that whether it be one week two weeks
for four weeks it's at least short you
know because say five years ago people
were at three months six months a year
right right right and i know that even
you know one of the first groups i
talked about was in vienna austria and
he was this one guy was telling me that
now he knows when i get in in the
morning I need to do this because i knew
know what i need to have by monday where
when he had a three-month release he
walked in and Blake what should i do
today you know and didn't really have a
clear cut you know and then that makes
you work a lot of overtime at the end
because you don't you know you build
yourself up so that you didn't do enough
early on so I don't know you know one
week to week versus four weeks you know
what the impact of that would be I don't
know do you think so you're the customer
of our research do you think it is you
think it is I think five sizes one
problems oh thank you bunch of
development you try and do and I also
think that would help us get me on this
I brand myself by my interrogation lane
form recommendation practice Microsoft
has a whole different set of problems
from a lot of the places that you see
the agile movement guys working in you
know so you know you come in with data
that says team sizes of 7 8 15 people
and then you talk to executives who say
well I've got 2,000 people in my group
and currently our product cycle is three
years I nice that's a medium sized
problem from Microsoft as a null set of
executives with an even bigger problem
than that so it's very difficult to get
them to recognize that this stuff could
be positive so figuring out how you
scale it across the different the me to
the problem sizes I think really
important
we could do things yeah I'd be happy to
work with you on that I was hoping to
see more real data on improvements in
customer satisfaction fortunately the
starting was usually na yeah yeah hey
buddy if in your future studies you
could focus more on real frisson okay
any other questions yeah I kind of like
to see more about people who have heavy
methodologies that they're currently
using you know with a lot of process and
a lot of overhead and what happens as
they shift more towards the agile side
of the spectrum like I don't really care
if you're saying stay here or what have
you I just want to know we used to be
much more processor than
and now we're trying to get more agile
because
constantly trying to advocating
aighty through here very early
so if i don't like this
okay and so savor that it was completely
bad so they had 250 people hi process it
went to agile and so within that what
what are you interested in culture or
well there's a lot of questions what one
of them is adaptation how do you get the
team to change their mindset from what
everybody knows is a waterfall right and
I mean this is the way it's always been
to what you've done things to now we're
doing something very different we're a
little out of our comfort swear a lot
out of our comfort zone you know and you
know we've got eyes watching it so how'd
it kind of manage of course it's just
the sort of do you take a dip in
productivity then come way up or you
know those kinds of right and so this is
within so saber was may be different
because they're vice president said you
will do it where yours is more of a like
IBM where you would like it and maybe
some other people would like it but
they're not being addicted it's for
evangelizing and trying to get a line
chair to embrace new ideas
that may be important they already have
the deed done the whole g complicate the
Virginia's at the FG model thing of
things get worse it will he get back up
ash you want a belt trust in an
executive that okay we're three weeks
into this and things have got worse but
trust us it will get better and be nice
to have the reference data so rather
than just sure point here we were here
and the point d we were here what
happened in between the Dakota and for
how long and had quickly to come back up
as you have that date already that would
be the only refuge have north and so
little and only on a different case
study that was just test driven
development where there was a four-month
project and the team did say it slowed
us down because it's hard to learn how
to test and it did slowed us down but by
the end of the four months they didn't
exceed their resource estimates or
anything so they made up for it within
four months going down and then coming
up that's the only reference i have but
i'll look out for that
anything else okay thank you
you